wir wollen direkt mal nach schloss
meseberg schauen heute beginnt dort
nämlich eine zweitägige klausurtagung
des bundeskabinetts zum kurs in der
ukraine politik und hier sehen wir schon
erste bilder von den ankünften bei
diesem treffen sollen laut
bundesregierung ja alle themen rund um
den russischen angriffskrieg diskutiert
werden als gäste werden auch die
ministerpräsidentin von schweden und
finnland erwartet beide länder überlegen
zurzeit der nato beizutreten und gleich
erwarten wir auch ein statement von
kanzler olaf scholz ja gestern hatte der
ja noch mal bekräftigt nicht selbst nach
kiel fahren zu wollen weil frank walter
steinmeier zuvor ausgeladen worden war
die kritik aus kirche kam prompt ja und
cdu-chef märz hingegen der möchte heute
eben nach kiel fahren ja und sobald der
kanzler dann vor die mikros tritt da
sind wir dann natürlich live dabei
man muss sagen es brodelt ordentliche
vor dieser reise von friedrich merz
grund ist der sächsische cdu
ministerpräsident kretschmann er dürfte
in der union ein mittleres politisches
erdbeben ausgelöst haben denn entgegen
der linie seiner partei hat er sich nun
auch der forderung von knapp 30
prominenten rund um alice schwarzer
angeschlossen die haben sich in einem
brief an bundeskanzler olaf scholz gegen
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
ausgesprochen ihre sorge dass sie den
krieg weiter an und bringe auch
deutschland in gefahr alice schwarzer
reinhard mey und auch der schauspieler
lars eidinger sind einige der
unterzeichnung ist ja und nun kommt also
kretzschmar immerhin einer der führenden
cdu politiker und sagt nach
bild-informationen in der gemeinsamen
präsidiumssitzung von cdu und csu
folgendes der offene brief an den
kanzler bildet nicht die mehrheit der
veröffentlichten meinung ab aber
durchaus die mehrheitsmeinung der
gesellschaft auch meine diese position
muss auch von der union berücksichtigt
werden es gibt allen grund diesem land
zu helfen auch mit waffen es geht aber
darum einen waffenstillstand zu
erzwingen russland will auch danach eine
realität sein und sanktionen treffen uns
zum großen teil selbst und das nachdem
bereits vor einem jahr er möchte ich in
die kritik geraten war wegen seiner
putin freundlichen politik da hat er
noch kontakt zu putin gesucht war erst
nicht empfangen worden konnte dann mit
ihm telefonieren und hier sehen wir ein
bild noch wie die sich dann später noch
getroffen ja darüber müssen wir
natürlich sprechen bildpolitik chef jan
schäfer ist bei uns im studio also das
müssen jetzt mal ein bisschen
auseinander drüsen erst hat die union
ehrung mächtig nach schweren waffen
gerufen hat also den kanzler unter druck
gesetzt hat ihn richtig getrieben hat
gesagt das muss jetzt passieren jetzt
kommt ausgerechnet einer aus dem eigenen
reihen und sagt nein also das ist jetzt
nicht unbedingt die mehrheitsmeinung da
muss man auch minder meinungen
respektieren und schießt dagegen
wir dachten jetzt eigentlich die spd hat
ein problem hat die union jetzt auch 1
union hat ein problem vor allem im osten
und wir sehen es an michael kretschmer
und ihr habt ja auch gerade schon gesagt
wir haben die bilder ja auch gesehen
michael kretschmer wladimir putin es
gibt enge verbindungen zwischen sachsen
auch zwischen dem ministerpräsidenten
der einen hang auch nach russland hat
und das hat auch damit zu tun dass muss
einfach zu sagen dass die ost-cdu also
die cdu in den neuen bundesländern viele
viele mitglieder hat die sehr russen
freundlich sind die
spd wirft märz ja auch vor die reise zu
instrumentalisieren es ist ja wahlkampf
in nordrhein westfalen und auch in
schleswig holstein haben sie dann punkt
getroffen also mich wundert dass die spd
jetzt von instrumentalisierung redet sie
hat selbst ein ihrer abgeordneten
geschickt den
vorsitzenden des europa aus dass des
auswärtigen ausschuss michael row das
ist dann noch gefahren der vorsitzende
des europa-ausschusses toni hofreiter
mitglied der grünen und die vorsitzende
des verteidigungsausschusses
fdp-politikerin marie-agnes
strack-zimmermann also die ampel hatte
schon drei politiker die jetzt auch
keine minister ämter innehaben in kiew
und jetzt fährt der oppositionsführer
also immerhin der chef der stärksten und
größten oppositionspartei im deutschen
bundestag ebenfalls nach kiew und da
verwundert ist dann schon dass man da
von politischen spielchen spricht ich
glaube es wäre eigentlich besser wenn
der bundeskanzler selbst einmal fahren
würde dann müsste er sich und seine
partei auch nicht über so eine reise auf
regen hatte gestern im zdf noch einmal
begründet dass er eben nicht fährt weil
frank walter steinmeier ausgeladen wurde
nun hat männicke der ukrainische
botschafter das kommentiert mit den
worten ja eine beleidigte leberwurst zu
spielen das sei nicht besonders
staatsmännisch stimmst leben dazu man
kann sicherlich über die wortwahl des
ukrainischen botschaft dass hier in
deutschland
unterschiedlicher meinung sein am ende
sehen wir aber dass olaf scholz sich
durch seine art nicht nach kiew reisen
zu wollen was ist ihr habt auch schon
vor der ausladung von frank walter
steinmeier thema gewesen selbst in einem
falle manövriert hat aus der er jetzt
eigentlich gar nicht mehr raus kommen
kann würde er jetzt fahren dann hieß es
ist ja auf massiven politischen druck
fährt er nun nach kiew bleibt er weiter
hier in deutschland fährt nicht heißt es
ja er ist wie ein kleines stur kräftiges
kind und will nun nicht wenig benutzt
das wort beleidigte leberwurst das würde
ich jetzt nicht in den mund nehmen
unbedingt aber wir sehen olaf scholz hat
es vermisst oder vermissen lassen von
anfang an gleich zu beginn des krieges
eigentlich zu sagen sobald sich die
chance ergibt fahre ich nach kiew dann
hätte er zumindest dokumentiert er wir
reisen hätte das zeitfenster aber offen
gelassen und das hat er nicht getan so
und jetzt ist er halt in sechs mühle aus
dr meines erachtens auch eigentlich gar
nicht mehr herauskommt es sei denn er
beruft so etwas wie ein ukraine gipfel
hier in deutschland ein das wäre
zumindest eine chance einigermaßen
gesichtswahrend aus dieser sache
rauszukommen aber du glaubst er wird
nicht in die ukraine reisen also es wäre
nicht die erste kehrtwende von olaf
scholz wir haben dass er am thema
waffenlieferungen auch gesehen das heißt
ich würde mich da nicht zu 100 prozent
fest links sage nur egal was er jetzt
macht es ist eine lose lose situation
also verlieren verlieren situation für
ihn aus der einfach nur bestätigt
herauskommen kann was man tatsächlich
sagen kann ist dass die gesellschaft in
dieser frage doch ein bisschen mehr
gespalten zu sein scheint als man am
anfang dachte das hat eben märz auch bei
einem wahlkampfauftritt in olpe erlebt
da musste er sich schon auch gegen
heftige kritik während aber noch mal
rein
meine damen unter
in diesem land gibt es meinungsfreiheit
und da kann jeder reden und sagen was er
will und es können sogar sie dort hinten
sie können jedes dummes zeug reden was
sie gerne wollen das ist der unterschied
zwischen olpe und moskau meine damen und
herren in moskau in moskau wären sie von
der sicherheitspolizei schon abgeführt
worden in europa dürfen sie schreiben
dürfen sie trakehnen dürfen sie machen
was sie wollen ich gebe nur einen
hinweis wenn sie beklagen dass wir in
deutschland nicht genug meinungsfreiheit
haben dann stellen sie sich doch bitte
mal die frage ob sie nicht in der art
und weise wie sie heute hier
herumschreien und herum pfeifen die
demokratie mehr beschädigen als jedes
andere mittel unserer politischen
auseinandersetzung sie da hinten machen
unsere demokratie kaputt
soweit also der cdu chef friedrich merz
das ist eine einschätzung dazu hat einen
punkt hat er natürlich ein punkt das
gehört dazu so hat das helmut kohl
übrigens früher auch gemacht er wurde ja
auch oft in wahlkampfveranstaltungen
oder generell bei auftritten
ausgepfiffen hat sich dann immer ein
paar minuten lang auch an die opfer und
die protestler gewann meistens zur
belustigung der derjenigen die dann
parteimitglieder cdu parteimitglieder
gewesen sind aber natürlich hat
friedrich merz ein punkt in dem er sagt
hier darf man zweifeln und jedermann
auch lautstark kritik äußern in moskau
wäre man dafür abgeführt worden und
unter protest hat sich auch der
bundeskanzler olaf scholz am tag zuvor
geäußert und da war mir noch mal
reinhören was er gesagt hat ähnlich
emotional
wir werden die bürger durch schützen mit
geld mit humanitärer hilfe aber auch das
muss gesagt werden wir werden sie
unterstützen dass sie sich verteidigen
kann mitmachen liefern die viele andere
länder immer unter wasser
das ist es notwendig dass die kirche
jeden pazifismus ich respektiere jede
haltung des buchs einem bürger der
ukraine schöne stücke wie gesagt wird er
solle sich gegen die polizeiaktion ohne
waffen verteidigen es ist unsere zeit
gewonnen
so das war also bundeskanzler scholze so
emotional hatte man ihn selten gesehen
wir haben es eben in unserem kleinen
split auch gesehen annalena baerbock ist
gerade in meseberg angekommen hat gerade
das schloss betreten und wir warten ja
auch noch auf eine weitere statement von
urlaub scholze ähnlich emotional würde
sicherlich nicht werden in meseberg
sowie ihnen da gesehen haben aber ja was
sagen uns jetzt diese beiden
veranstaltungen wenn wir sehen wie groß
dann doch die kritik tatsächlich an den
schweren waffenlieferungen ist es ist
wirkliches stimmungsbild in deutschland
oder war das jetzt sagen wir mal einfach
nur im kleinen eine veranstaltung auf
der das ganze vielleicht ein bisschen
falsch rüber kommt weil die dagegen sind
so laut war ich glaube man kann
feststellen auch in umfragen dass sich
in gewisser weise ich möchte nicht sagen
etwas dreht aber dass sich die
gewichtung etwas verschiebt bis vor
kurzem gab es eine deutliche mehrheit
zum beispiel was das thema lieferung von
schweren waffen also auch von panzern in
die ukraine angeht da gab es eine klare
mehrheit weit über 50 prozent der
bundesbürger haben auch in umfragen
gesagt das ist okay jetzt sehen wir neue
umfragen von ende april
die sind sehen ein sehr ausgeglichenes
verhältnis also beide knapp 50 prozent
das heißt auch der anteil derjenigen der
sagt nein auf keinen fall schwere waffen
zu liefern das sind natürlich dann auch
jene die wir jetzt gerade sowohl bei der
veranstaltung von olaf scholz als auch
bei friedrich merz gesehen haben also
die die sagen nein auf keinen fall
schwere waffen liefern dieser anteil
nimmt deutlich zu und nimmt wie wir auch
sehr war hörbar aber warum ist das so
warum dreht sich bis in die meinung in
der gesellschaft ist die angst
tatsächlich jetzt doch größer geworden
dass putin im falle solcher lieferungen
tatsächlich ein dritter weltkrieg
auslösen könnte geht es darum dass es
ölembargos geben könnte dass es dann
doch bei uns zu hause ein bisschen
kälter wird als wir sie uns anfang
vorgestellt haben ich habe das viele
bürger spüren dass der krieg und da
haben wir an den benzinpreisen auch
schon gesehen aber bei der frage jetzt
kommt ein gas embargo zum beispiel kommt
ein öl-embargo merken dass dieser krieg
mit seinen auswirkungen immer näher an
uns heran rückt also wir sehen es ja
auch bei den lebensmittelpreisen man
einkaufen geht im supermarkt da wird
vieles jetzt deutlich teurer das hat
auch zu tun mit dem krieg in der ukraine
ganz interessant ist dass wir glaube ich
eine stärkere spaltung jetzt auch wieder
sehen in dieser kriegs frage in der
gesellschaft denn die das institut in sa
hat für bild ermittelt dass erstmals
drei
grünen-politiker drei grünen minister
die beliebtesten minister in deutschland
sind robert habeck ist an einigen wochen
vorne annalena baerbock auf ba2 manchmal
auch auf 1 das war jetzt klar aber
plötzlich ist auf platz drei cem özdemir
der agrarminister das heißt wir haben
ein trio ein grünes trio an der spitze
in deutschland ausgerechnet die
klassische pazifismus pazifisten partei
die grünen kommen also in der
beliebtheit jetzt ganz ganz nach vorne
und das interessant denn gerade die
minister sind es ja auch die so kann man
schon sagen in gewisser weise dieser
grüne partei ganz anders positionieren
ist eine partei die für die freiheit
eintritt das hat haben die grünen nicht
mehr oder weniger in der spitze
zumindest immer gemacht aber die auch
ganz eindeutig für waffenlieferungen für
einen harten kampf gegen wladimir putin
und seine truppen eintritt so und das
führt dazu dass die grünen-mitglieder
oder bzw wähler von auch der spd
rüberziehen die mit der politik von olaf
scholz zum beispiel gar nicht zufrieden
sind werden was versprichst du dir heute
von der klausurtagung in meseberg was
wären wir da erwarten können speziell
auch von der rede von olaf scholz
also es geht zum einen um die frage
weiterer waffenlieferungen das ist ein
kernthema wie kann man der ukraine zum
einen mit waffen mit schwerem gerät
weiterhelfen aber natürlich auch
finanziell es wird um das thema steuern
gehen nach allem was wir hören gibt es
auch beim finanzminister gewisse
unzufriedenheit darüber dass die grünen
mit immer neuen steuervorschlägen kommen
gestern auch die grüne parteivorsitzende
ricarda lang die plötzlich darüber
sprach dass man firmen die jetzt während
der kriegszeit besonders hohe gewinne
einfahren speziell besteuern müsste eine
über gewinn steuer hat sie das gesandten
genannt man könnte auch sagen eine
kriegs steuern die sie einführen wird
und natürlich wird es einmal mehr um die
frage gehen wann reißt olaf scholz
endlich nach ihr und er hat sich ja
gestern im zdf geäußert im politik talk
da waren wir noch mal rein jahren er hat
nämlich begründet warum er nicht nach
kiew gereist
ich finde dass es doch immerhin ein ganz
bemerkenswerter vorgang ist dass der
präsident der bundesrepublik deutschland
damit eine mehrheit wie glaube ich
niemand vor ihm in der bundesversammlung
wenige wochen vorher für eine zweite
amtszeit nominiert worden ist ausgeladen
worden ist das ist dem immer noch
entgegen wir sind der sache das steht
der sache im weg was wie kann das
ausgeräumt werden erstmal glaube ich
muss es für uns als demokraten
demokraten dazu gehören dass wir über
diese sache kein zweifel haben das kann
man nicht machen und es kann nicht
funktionieren dass man von einem land
das so viel militärische hilfe so viel
finanzielle hilfe leistet das gebraucht
wird wenn es um die sicherheitsgarantien
geht die für die zeit der ukraine in der
zukunft wichtig sind dass man dann sagt
der präsident kann aber nicht kommen
ja soweit also olaf scholz aber nicht
nur er hat sich gestern geäußert sondern
auch robert habeck da ging es um ein
mögliches öl-embargo oder hat habe ich
dann tatsächlich gesagt das könnte
frühestens in ein paar monaten kommen
liegt zum einen daran dass eben nicht
alle staaten in der eu sich einig sind
zum anderen damals damit dass man putin
eben auch nicht die möglichkeit geben
möchte einen workaround zu finden so zu
sagen und sich eben von woanders her
dann sein geld zu holen heißt das jetzt
tatsächlich das ist im grunde genommen
wenn ein öl embargo kommen würde der
ukraine doch gar nicht mehr helfen würde
weil es viel zu spät kommt uns aber inne
doch wirtschaftlich sehr sehr schwere
lage bringen würde macht das dann noch
sinn also
versuchen wir einmal das sind die
reihenfolge jetzt zu bringen genau heute
sind die sitze die eu-energieminister
noch einmal zusammen und mutmaßlich wird
heute dieses öl embargo beschlossen
jetzt ist die große frage wann tritt es
in kraft tritt ist möglicherweise schon
morgen in kraft vielleicht wie einigen
wochen oder in einigen monaten wird das
richtig in den zwischentönen auch
verstanden habe könnte es auch so etwas
wie eine abstufung geben einige länder
die vorangehen andere die ein bisschen
später folgen mit der klaren botschaft
aber europa steigt insgesamt aus robert
habeck hat ja gestern auf den ungarn
vorgeworfen dass sie wieder ihr eigenes
spielchen spielen also es könnte sein
dass auch der ungarische regierungschef
orban ein bisschen tuckert in der
hoffnung dass ihm die eu irgendwelche
zusätzlichen ausgleichszahlungen passt
dann leistet so das würde passen ganz
genau wir sehen aber auch zum einen
würde ein embargo natürlich dazu führen
dass in die russische staatskasse
weniger geld fließen würde das ist
richtig wir sehen aber auch und das ist
ganz frisch heute kommen zahlen der
ölmultis exxon war am freitag dran mit
einem mit einer verdopplung des gewinns
im zeitraum januar bis märz und gerade
sind die zahlen von bp gekommen bp hat
im ersten quartal also zwischen januar
und märz in wir erinnern uns da sind die
ex die benzinpreise explodiert den
höchsten quartalsgewinn seit zehn jahren
eingefahren also das ist ein spiel mit
vielen vielen seiten einer medaille
zum einen das ziel natürlich putin den
geldhahn abzudrehen aber man wird
sicherlich auch immer da noch mit namen
der gewinner haben und wir sehen dass
die ölmultis an dieser ganzen krise auch
extrem gut verdient haben in unsere
diskussion wollen wir gerne unseren
reporter paul ronzheimer aus kiew mit
dazuholen paul die das öl embargo würde
das der ukraine helfen und wie schnell
müsste das kommt
das öl-embargo würde der ukraine
natürlich helfen denn alles was druck
auf putin macht alles was dafür sorgt
dass die kriegskasse weniger gefüllt
wird alles was dafür sorgt dass nicht
noch mehr panzer gekauft panzer
produziert munition nachgeliefert werden
können bringt etwas aber aus sicht der
ukraine geht es vor allem ums gas da ist
das große der große geldhahn da ist das
was wirklich wehtut und deswegen immer
wenn man mit ukrainischen offiziellen
spricht heißt es dass ist gut und
richtig aber vor allem das gas embargo
muss kommen
dennoch paul damit etwas bringen würde
müsste ist relativ bald kommen wenn wir
jetzt töne hören ja das könnte eventuell
erst in ein paar monaten passieren wird
so was in der ukraine aufgenommen
in der ukraine will man es so schnell
wie möglich natürlich denn jeder tag
kostet hier menschen leben das ist auch
das was wir immer wieder sagen müssen
wenn wir in der front unterwegs sind da
ist kein verständnis dafür dass das in
deutschland in europa auf der welt
länger dauert da sagt man wir brauchen
jetzt druck wir brauchen jetzt warten
wir brauchen jetzt hilfe das ist das was
wir hier hören an der front auf der
anderen seite muss man eines auch ganz
klar sagen ich gehe nicht davon aus dass
der krieg in ein paar wochen beendet
wird oder beendet ist das wird ein
langer krieg das könnte monate dauern
von daher sind auch mittelfristige und
langfristige perspektiven wenn es denn
ich kurzfristig geht immer noch etwas
was helfen kann aber du warst im donbass
an der front unterwegs hat uns ganz
aktuelle bilder mitgebracht da waren wir
jetzt mal reingucken
der donbass im osten der ukraine drohen
aufnahmen die die aktuelle frontlinie
zeigen sollen in unmittelbarer nähe bild
vize paul ronzheimer
hier gab es vor 30 minuten einschläge so
sieht die donners front aus und wir
haben im hintergrund dort wo der rauch
zu sehen ist die frontlinie hier im
donbass die umkämpfte front linie aber
es ist mittlerweile mehr ein krieg der
artillerie denn der verschieden gewehre
und deswegen feuern ukrainer und russen
in unterschiedlichen zeiträumen hier
auseinander bei dem keiner sagen uns wir
haben nicht genug munition momentan um
auf die russischen angriffe zu antworten
ganz in der nähe trifft paul auf eine
ukrainische militäreinheit die an
vorderster front kämpft wie würdest du
die aktuelle russische offensive
beschreiben
ich würde sagen sie ist stabil
artillerie beschuss von morgens bis
abends
es gibt kaum zeiten in denen sie nicht
schießen
bei regen oder bei starken wind oder bei
nacht wenn es schwierig ist die schüsse
zu korrigieren sind die einzigen zeiten
in der sie uns nicht beschießen
um die russischen stellungen beobachten
zu können verwenden die ukraine immer
öfter drohnen wozu genau werden die
drohnen eingesetzt und wie wichtig sind
sie im krieg hier im donbass die
aufklärung aus der luft ist immens
wichtig fast alle unsere militärischen
erfolge basieren auf der aufklärung aus
der luft
und wie funktionieren diese drohen hier
sind kleine kameras und mit denen ihr
die position der russen beobachtet
richtig ja wir beobachten damit die
stelle harrison zu sowjetzeiten mussten
wir uns anschleichen war dass davos zu
kommen heute können wir eine drohne
schicken
die haben die satelliten wir haben die
drohen woher bekommt ihr diese drohen
wer liefert diese drohen sind sie aus
der ukraine
wir sind ganz gewöhnliche chinesische
drohen die wir nun einstellung gebaut
haben es sind die neuesten modelle aber
jeder kann sie ganz normal kaufe
die tatsächliche frontlinie ist nur
wenige kilometer entfernt
jetzt sehen wir die zerstörung der stadt
das ist marie kann richtig ja das ist
marie kahn wir sind nur wenige kilometer
weg
kann man den feind sehen nein erst wenn
wir darüber fliegen sind das die drohen
die den kriegsverlauf entscheiden werden
nehmen uns noch mal mit sagt uns wie ist
die militärische lage denn aktuell im
donbass können die russen weitere
geländegewinne verzeichnen oder nicht
die militärische lage ist besser als man
erwartet hätte aber schlechter als die
teilweise auch von der ukrainischen
regierung geschrieben wird so klar muss
man das sagen gestern waren wir dort an
der frontlinie und dort hat man uns
gesagt natürlich verlieren sie dörfer
bislang aber noch keine großen städte
und es gibt große probleme an der front
es gibt nicht genügend munition es gibt
nicht genügend waffen es gibt nicht
genügend moderne panzer das sagen uns
die soldaten da das sagt uns der
kommandeur dort von daher braucht es
dringend so sagen sie eine auffrischung
der truppen es braucht dringend das
material über das wir so lange
diskutiert haben und dann so sagen sie
hat man eine chance ansonsten stellt man
sich auf einen langen krieg an man
rechne nicht damit dass am 9 mai also am
tag der kapitulation nazideutschlands
wirklich irgendetwas großes von wladimir
putin präsentiert werden könnte an
gelände gewinnen aber man geht fest
davon aus dass es danach noch brutaler
noch schlimmer und noch zerstörerischer
werden kann vielen dank an bild vize
paul ronzheimer live aus der ukraine
und danke auch an janne schäfer danke
dass du bei uns wir werden natürlich im
laufe des tages noch mal über dieses
thema diskutieren und wir sind natürlich
gespannt was olaf scholz auch gleich in
meseberg sagen wird